I'm quite shy and when asked questions
in public,
I find it hard to articulate a good
answer,
but we'll come up with a strong response
hours or days later.
Any advice?
Yeah,
I have some advice.
One is that,
um,
well you're probably introverted day so
you're not as verbally fluent as an
extrovert would be a not quite as fast
on the draw verbally,
but you know,
that means you need some more time to
contemplate and maybe you're high in
negative emotion too.
Um,
because shyness can be a combination of
introversion and high negative emotion.
It can be one or the other,
but,
but technically shy is introverted.
Um,
anyways,
what I would certainly recommend for you
is that if you're faced with a
complicated question,
especially one that has to do with an
important decision in your life that you
say,
I need to sleep on it or I need a couple
of days and not to answer,
um,
on the draw.
I mean,
I think that's true even for extroverts.
I think if you're at called upon to
offer your opinion about something
complex,
then it's perfectly reasonable to say,
look,
that's a really hard question.
I'm not going to give you a casual
answer.
I need to think about it for a couple of
days.
So the advice would be because you find
it hard to articulate a good answer,
don't allow yourself to be rushed.
And the second is to understand that
this is part of your temperament there.
There isn't anything wrong with it.
It's just,
it's,
it's how you're wired.
So
what causes a person to hoard is due to
low conscientiousness.
What is generally the best course of
treatment?
Um,
it's usually a consequence of relatively
high in neuroticism.
Um,
and it's tangled in with disgust,
sensitivity as well.
Um,
people who hoard have a hard time.
They feel guilty if they throw things
away because the thing's still have some
residual utility.
The best course of treatment is well,
behavioral therapies probably the best
course of treatment.
And to plan what needs to be thrown away
and to work with a person that can help
you make the hard decisions that,
that need to be made if you're hoarding.
Um,
all that,
all that hoarded material is an,
it's decisions that have been put off.
So a lot of that is high neuroticism.
I,
some of that can be a consequence of low
conscientiousness as well.
So the best course of treatment is to
find someone to help you plan how to
approach the,
the horde.
Very complicated.
So,
all right.
Which Hogwarts house would you be in?
Yeah,
well I think I'd have the same issue as
Harry Potter when the hat was first put
on.
It would think that I might make a
perfectly good Dennis and of slitherin.
So,
um,
although that probably wouldn't be where
I would end up.
So
what is your take on an astrological
basis for significant dates in religious
stories?
Example,
Christian religion is a parody on the
worship of the sun.
Well,
it's certainly not a parody.
Um,
religion,
religious systems as the expand tend to
incorporate everything that's quasi
religious in the culture.
And there's certainly no shortage of
solar symbolism in Christianity.
I mean,
it's not fluke that that Christ is the
son and there are 12 disciples just like
there are 12 astrological houses and
it's not fluke that,
um,
the birth of Christ takes place
essentially at the same time as,
as,
as the shortest day of the year.
And the rebirth of the sun.
All of these things line up.
Now,
whether that synchronicity or whether
it's the attempt by the collective
imagination of human beings to align
everything under a single truth,
that's a very difficult thing to say.
Or maybe there's a single truth at work.
But the idea that Christian religion is
a parody on the worship of the sun is
not,
is definitely not the case.
It's more like it's incorporated
elements of the worship of the sun over
thousands and thousands of years.
And that's a very complicated issue.
If you're interested in that,
you could read I on a I o.
N it's booked by Carl Young,
which is like the most terrifying book
I've ever read.
And so you could,
there's a deeper analysis of the
relationship between astrological
speculation.
Um,
and,
and the emergence of complex religious
stories.
So
my brother 29 is sick at home with
burnout.
He's a perfectionist,
has anxiety,
has trouble dealing with stress.
How can I help them become stronger?
Well,
you could encourage him to go talk to a
therapist.
You could tell him to go find broadly,
make an appointment with three of them.
Go talk to each one for an hour.
And if he likes one of them and he finds
when who listens,
then he can go back a couple more times.
But it isn't going to hurt him to go
once,
at least to go talk.
Um,
it's also possible that he needs someone
to talk to them about medication.
You know,
antidepressants,
if he's in real trouble.
Antidepressants often very helpful to
people,
not always,
but often.
And so that is a lot better.
Taking an antidepressant beats the hell
out of being sick at home with burnout
and it's attended dangers,
cognitive dangers,
dangers of stress induced illness,
dangers of suicidal ideation and all
that sort of thing.
Um,
I would also recommend that he tried the
self authoring program.
If he's at home,
he could write about his past,
he could write about his present,
he could write about his future,
he can do a bad job,
he can do it over days.
I think that,
I mean we have evidence that the program
is extremely helpful to people and
there's evidence from other researchers
that such programs really help.
So that would,
that would be something that he could
do.
Well,
he's sitting at home and it's not going
to hurt him.
I'm going over some of the more complex
material might make them feel slightly
worse in the short term,
but the long term payoff is very,
very high.
So,
um,
that's what I would recommend.
Encourage him to go talk to somebody he
knew and he needs to make,
the planning needs to come to terms with
what's happened to him.
And He needs to make a plan and he might
need to talk to somebody for a long time
to figure out what the hell's going on.
You know?
And we also don't want to rule out,
and neither does he,
the possibility that there's something
physical wrong,
you know,
because there's increasing evidence that
the depressive disorders and that would
include anxiety,
are consequence of,
of such conditions as,
as generalized inflammation.
And that's really worth looking into.
So I think a lot of the things that we
think are psychological have a more
pronounced physical basis.
So.